Breasts. They provide nourishment for our
babies, they are one of the few organs not
fully developed at birth, and of course are
a major obsession in western culture. Yet
there is so much about breasts that isn’t
discussed or is deemed taboob, sorry “taboo”.
So, what does science say about breasts?
Forget water into wine - what about blood
into milk? Proteins, sugars, and fat are pulled
from a mother's blood supply to make milk,
and it is this action that has made mammals
so successful. Unlike birds or reptiles, whose
young are dependent on parents to bring them
outside food such as insects, mammals, from
the word mammary, access their nutrition at
a young age from the secretion of a mother's
milk.
Breasts come in all shapes and sizes and though
there is a positive correlation between breast
size and weight, genes also play a crucial
role in the size of boobs. 50% of the time
one breast is larger than the other, most
commonly the left boob, known as breast asymmetry.
This asymmetry is normal and though scientists
aren’t entirely clear why, a possible contributor
is the hormonal changes that happen during
puberty. On top of this, the size of your
breasts vary from week to week! Yup, the production
of estrogen and progesterone throughout the
menstrual cycle changes the size of your breasts.
Both men and women have nipples and mammary
glands, but usually only women have them develop
at puberty. This characteristic is uniquely
human as other mammals breasts only enlarge
during nursing. The ring of pigmented skin
surrounding the nipple is called the areola
which is covered in little bumps called Montgomery's
Gland. While lactating, the glands make oily
secretions that keep the nipple lubricated
and may also release compounds to make the
nipple seem yummy for a baby.
The nipple isn’t composed of a single orifice
but has many tiny holes you cannot see with
the naked eye. After having a baby, receptors
in the nipple detect when the baby begins
to suckle, sending messages to the mother's
brain, causing a release of oxytocin and continued
production of prolactin. Oxytocin causes cells
that line the mammary glands to contract and
is also known as the cuddle hormone, as it
enhances the bonding experience between mother
and child. The hormone prolactin is essential
in making milk. This whole hormonal process
can be triggered after only hearing a baby
cry, even if it isn’t your baby!
Babies love breasts, but so do people. Research
has found that people spend more time observing
large breasts with a certain hip to width
ratio - potentially explaining why breast
augmentation surgeries are the most prevalent
form of plastic surgery, with 300,000 surgeries
being performed in 2014...in America alone.
However, the same research shows that people
prefer breasts of all different shapes and
sizes, and medium sized breasts were actually
rated as statistically most attractive. Breasts
don’t only create joy for others, but also
for oneself. Studies show that stimulation
of nipples enhanced sexual arousal in 82%
of women and 52% of men. Interestingly an
fMRI scan that mapped the brain's response
to clitoral and vaginal self-stimulation,
found that the same areas lit up when a woman
stimulated her nipples.
Despite being an amazing source of both nutrition
and pleasure, breasts are incredibly vulnerable.
Breast cancer is the most prevalent form of
cancer in North America. Cells that divide
often are at a higher risk of mutations than
cells that don’t divide - and because breasts
change and grow over the course of our lives,
these cells are frequently dividing. The hormone
estrogen also stimulates breast cell division,
and there are environmental chemicals found
in pesticides, industrial products, and even
our food that mimic estrogen and can influence
cell growth, increasing the risk of breast
cancer. Research is discovering new risk factors
of breast cancer such as breast density, age
of first pregnancy, and genetic predisposition
to breast cancer genes such as BRCA1 and BRCA2.
This scientific knowledge can help increase
prevention.
Although they are vulnerable, they are incredible,
and regardless of shapes and sizes they are
an essential aspect of sustaining human life
and defining us as a species. Thank you boobs.
Wanna learn even more about boobs? Check out
our latest AsapTHOUGHT video where we debunk
some myths about Why Women Have Breasts. Click
on the screen or use the link in the description.
And subscribe for me weekly science videos.